so I got a hard segue to Rolling Stone
Trump's major announcement was a scammy
superhero themed nft collection for 99
you can now own a digitally generated
image of the former president cosplaying
as an astronaut fighter pilot sheriff or
red carpet celebrity uh I think it's
hilarious his video release was really
funny he goes uh hopefully I'm your
favorite President greater than Lincoln
greater than Washington and if you and
if you buy an nft you enter into a
sweepstakes for a chance to win a bunch
of great prizes like dinner with me I
don't know if it's a great prize but
maybe but it's what we got but I think
it was funny that he's like I'm better
than Lincoln and Washington and eating
dinner with me might not be a good prize
so so look he's a funny guy I think what
was cringe about this was that people
thought he was going to endorse someone
for RNC chair he was going to announce a
VP he was going to put forth a major
policy proposal but instead he's selling
nfts right around the time FTX collapses
and what six months after nft cheese
became worthless yeah yeah sorry how
many did you buy oh seven no I bought
none I'm not gonna buy it I'm trying so
hard because I I still really like the
guy best present in my lifetime but I'm
trying really hard to spin it in my head
I'm like how can I convince myself this
was a good announcement and I I can't do
it you know but but the the thing that
his announcement did demonstrate is
something that I have I have said to
Trump's critics for years which is they
say he's an egomaniac narcissist and I
say yeah you know he has his name on
buildings but he has a kind of humility
like for instance he had this comment
when he was president he said uh someone
accused him of drinking a beer he said
I've never drunk a beer okay I've never
I'm probably the only person who can say
I've never drunk a beer it's the only
good thing you can say about me and it
was an expression of humility it was a
self-effacing thing as he is saying here
you know when he when he boasts about
everything he's talking like a New
Yorker but he's usually joking I I just
I I laughed so hard when he was like
maybe it's not a good prize I don't know
I'm like that was masterfully done he's
really good at that kind of stuff yeah I
mean he's getting a lot of pushback
especially from a lot of his supporters
today America needs a superhero big
announcement tomorrow here's my Pokemon
cards and I'm like you got to be kidding
me and uh look at this look at this oh
yeah this is good look at it look at
look at he's shooting lasers infomercial
hello everyone this is Donald
hopefully your favorite President of all
time better than Lincoln better than
Washington with an important
announcement to make I'm doing my first
official Donald J Trump nft collection
right here and right now they're called
Trump digital trading cards these cards
feature some of the really incredible
artwork pertaining to my life and my
career it's been very exciting you can
collect your Trump digital cards just
like a baseball card or other
Collectibles here's one of the best
parts each card comes with an automatic
chance to win amazing prizes like dinner
with me I don't know if that's an
amazing prize that's what we have we're
golfing but it's what we have your
friends at one of my beautiful golf
courses yeah uh the prizes actually are
great like having a cocktail party with
your friends at Mar-A-Lago it's not a
bad fry I mean that sounds really fun
dinner with Trump would be extremely
interesting even if you don't like the
guy and playing golf with him that
sounds fun but a 100 gambling chip to
fight hope you win a chance to hang out
it's like not in this economy now no no
no I think I think the whole thing was a
mistake they should be 99 cents each and
he could sell 100 million of them or 10
million or 50 million
why do you gotta do bump stock Donnie
like that Tim yeah I thought you liked
him yeah why you gotta do him like that
I like the Abraham Accords I like trying
to negotiate peace with North Korea I
like setting timelines for withdrawal
from the Middle East I don't like him
for a whole lot of reasons there's a
tweet going around right now allegedly
from Baked Alaska saying quote I can't
believe I'm going to jail for an nft
salesman
this does bring some interesting
comments to where Trump's attention is
he's not on Twitter he's not in the
National discourse he's not making you
know a lot of strong stances on a lot of
the important things happening right now
he's selling 99 nfts now here's the
problem almost immediately right after
we have this story shatter the left-wing
censorship regime Trump announces 2024
Free Speech policy quote a Sinister
group of Deep State bureaucrat Silicon
Valley tyrants and activists and
depraved corporate news media have been
conspiring to manipulate and silence the
American people this was a very somber
and serious statement that came out like
right around the time as this nft
announcement
this should have been the major
announcement of course and people have
been like wow Trump's getting serious
what's the announcement he's promising
he's going to do something when he
becomes president of the United States
that doesn't really change it it's a
politician making promises it doesn't
really change anything that's a good
point but but the point is Donald Trump
has an announcement to make and at the
very least it would have been in of
political nature not selling nfts you
know I'm I'm all for the fun frivolity
silliness I mean I like that but it it
has to that has to be the cherry on top
of the Sunday of really doing something
and talking about issues that people
care about I mean to your point look
he's not in office right now so he can't
really do anything and he's not even on
Twitter so he can't talk that much but I
just I look and I think in Trump 2015
when also he was just talking right he
was just a candidate but Trump 2015 he
comes down that escalator he says what
no other Republican will say which is
that this immigration thing is horrible
and they're sending rapists and drug
dealers across and we got to do
something when he said you remember
Hillary Clinton's uh slogan was I'm with
her and Trump said that's a BS slogan
I'm with you you switch the subject and
the uh he said I'm with you and you
really felt like this guy's talking
about things that actually matter to me
NAFTA when was the last Republican to
challenge NAFTA ever you know Buchanan I
guess and and now you all we're seeing
is the frivolity all we're seeing is the
T he he you know here's and I just think
okay it's funny come on give me
something man he he he uh and it uh in
this statement he said within hours of
my inauguration I will sign an executive
order Banning any any federal department
or agency from colluding with any
organization business or person to
censor limit categorize or impede the
lawful speech of American citizens I
will then ban Federal money from being
used to label domestic speech miss or
disinformation I'll begin the process of
identifying and firing every Federal
bureaucrat who has engaged in domestic
censorship directly or indirectly et
cetera et cetera I I it's it's it's
topical it's playing to what's going on
with Elon and Twitter if this was his
major announcement it would have played
very well if he came out and said what
we have recently discovered in several
lawsuits as well as leaked information
from Big social networks that the
government had been colluding as
president I will end this people would
be like wow you know what Elon Musk
Twitter files just came out then Donald
Trump says I'm paying attention I know
what is worrying you and I will address
it would have been big it is big in a
sense it's just being overshadowed by
his weird late night infomercial you
know nft thing it could be he released
the nfts and then the Management's like
oh my God this is backfiring this is not
telling quick make a statement make a
statement what are you gonna do as
president I'm gonna do this I promise
this politicians make promises all the
time they rarely ever keep them
especially if they're campaigning how do
you know a politician's lying they're
campaigning that's when you know their
life is moving um no he kept more than
than most politicians and he didn't keep
all of it and they're not even close but
he kept a lot but previously before
before he became president of the United
States he promised to audit the Federal
Reserve he promised to investigate 911
he promised to look into Saudi Arabia's
involvement in 911 I mean he was talking
about a lot of big things you know again
didn't really kind of address them when
he was president but people don't want
to hear that people want to hear how is
he going to in Pennsylvania how is he
going to win Arizona because right now
there's no political road map for him
winning how why you'd have to talk about
graphene the only way no no I'm talking
about balance
I'm talking about ballot Harvest
I think he ends onto something if Donald
Trump comes out and says we don't need
your vote as long as we Advocate
graphene we're going to get every vote
anyway
industrial nation on Earth we're going
to lead the 21st century with the new
material metabolism it's all around him
no hold on hold on you know look at our
smug face is here we're all laughing
yeah but there there is a version of
reality where Donald Trump says forget
the politicking forget the gamesmanship
forget the ballot harvesting he walks
out and says graphene is a Wonder
material that will change everything and
bring jobs back and everyone just goes
he's right 100 million votes Lance
trying to build a space elevator we're
going to lead the lead the world in
space exploration like we need him
telling us what he wants to create for
the species if he has any chance of
winning so graphene's a metaphor he
needs to talk about his plans to build
and help America and to call out those
who seek his destruction like he was
doing in 2016. yeah graphene's literal
you need we're gonna make space elevator
tethers out of it I think what you're
really saying is no that is you're right
you're literally she needs a message
about industry some sort of Industry
that's what we need right now is
industry we don't need who's better we
don't need to see who's got the longer
you know I'm I'm not sure I'm no longer
graphing remember I'm not going to no
longer tether I'm not going to defend
the nft thing there are people who are
coming out saying it was a troll I'm
like dude get out of here the dude's
selling you stuff I really want to vote
for Donald Trump I want there to be a
reason to do so I want to see his
narrative art completed but it does feel
to me that he's finding a way to bow out
that's it yeah someone you think he's
like on retirement I said homie's
retirement in 2016 he's like you know
effectively calling Rose O'Donnell a fat
pig he's calling out the machine he's
mocking them openly to their faces
Michael Moore says he was a human
Molotov cocktail it was revenge for all
of the establishment games selling jobs
selling factories Outsourcing and
gutting this country 2020. I I see what
he did after he got like I I don't want
to vote for that guy but then I'm like
the economy is doing really well
pre-covered yeah he's Abraham Accords
he's got a bunch of Peace deals he's
actively trying to work on peace in the
Middle East and in North Korea and I'm
like okay school choice was a big thing
Banning uh uh um bomb stock no that was
bad but Banning the woke stuff from
Government Contracting I'm like not
perfect the bomb stock ban was very bad
his statements were very bad but I said
the piece in the Middle East stuff that
he's working on not perfect I get it I
will take it especially over Joe Biden
so I voted for him now all he's doing is
talking about 2020. he's tweeting about
his true thing about it non-stop selling
nfts and we get only tiny morsels of
some kind kind of policy position so I'm
just like dude you had me with the 2020
campaign I can now see what what what in
2016 worked why is it that now is Vander
2024 he's giving us his garbage hey no
no he's also telling us to get
vaccinated so remember to do that folks
well this is you know Ron DeSantis is
what I I know that some people don't
like Ron DeSantis or they used to like
Ron DeSantis but now they don't like Ron
DeSantis because Trump is running and
and whatever you think about the guy he
is one of the most masterful politicians
of our lifetime and he has found this
one issue in particular where he can
outflank Trump to the right and that's
on the vaccines and choosing to empanele
that grand jury and choosing to
investigate the MRNA Vex I mean it was
an absolute stroke of Genius and I don't
know how Trump answers that he can't
yeah we didn't especially when it came
to lockdowns when it came to covet and
when it came to operation warp speed he
can't so DeSantis just had a panel with
Joe latapo his uh secretary uh secretary
the the Surgeon General Surgeon General
yeah and uh what was it exactly can you
explain the panel that that they had
because I saw 10 20 seconds of it so
that well they're they're like five or
six
things that DeSantis is proposing right
now the most important one though is is
actually impaneling a grand jury to
investigate and potentially prosecute
the people who lied about these vaccines
from industry to to Public Authority and
so that that's a big deal because you
need teeth I mean as we're all kind of
talking about it's one thing to make a
promise on a campaign Trail or to send a
tweet but if you're actually holding
people to account for deception and
fraud and crimes you know those are the
kind of results that that people want
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time